yo
it's bfb the pacman
check me out on a bootleg calf podcast
man i'm grateful to be here
yellow lunch crew
all right look man boo like hell podcast
this guy i feel like i dm'd you like
last year sometime
yeah man and then finally you saw it and
then hit me like earlier this year like
i apologize that's all good man welcome
welcome to apologize the pac-man is here
bfb the pac-man is here
man i feel like i feel blessed i'm here
with bullet cam talking about
[ __ ]
man
driving to l.a bro you're not from here
don't drive here right like hire a
driver man that's some real [ __ ] i could
have told you that i saw you literally
pulled up in the whip driving it
yourself
you should everything hands-on like
everything like
i respect that i don't know everything
hands on me every artist they'd be like
damn y'all got no team like that i'd be
like man i just got managers i got two
managers you hear me one it's a hands-on
manager the other one go out there and
get to the big place the big place yeah
and
other than that
i'm out here in this water by myself
well you're very i feel like you're very
self-made man like you know the one
thing that uh
kind of caught my attention about you
was
i thought you
because cause because i think people
think of you as like funny
like you're a funny guy right like you
know like you're a character
but i i just was like yo this dude also
is hilarious like your bars are [ __ ]
fire like you're like so funny the [ __ ]
you be saying is like [ __ ] i'll be
saying to my friends when i'm not being
recorded
and that's in thank you bro
i need that clip
so when this come out
send me that clip that's some real [ __ ]
people mistake the [ __ ] that i say it's
funny
because i'm not right because because
i'm not rapping about ryan down a [ __ ]
blocking
killing [ __ ] and yeah i just cop 10 20
bricks and
[ __ ] i spent a hundred thousand on my
jury
no i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm yeah i'm talking
about this [ __ ] we we actually say
these are the things like most dudes are
[ __ ] around with their homies when
we're just shooting the [ __ ] and
[ __ ] off yeah for sure i'm gonna
always be me i'm always speak nobody is
saying this type i love it bro and i
remember meek mill right meek mill was
like uh
you need antibiotics stuff so can't hide
fish and put the laughing emoji he felt
that [ __ ] in his soul
he felt it
so many of your lines are
it's it's real [ __ ] you can feel bro i
just think it's normal normal dude [ __ ]
it's like yes we [ __ ] watch porn
we talk to our homies about the [ __ ]
we [ __ ] except me i'm married you know
what i'm saying formally obviously
congratulations thank you thank you you
know we we uh we make extremely
crude
inappropriate jokes
and
i was like we got a rapper now you got
eyes i got eyes we both me and we
understand yeah like i was talking with
mustard
mustard was talking about i make my
[ __ ] and kids leave the house so i can
beat my meat line and i've been there
you feel me like something bro i'm a
married man or when you oh
when you're a married man or when you in
a relationship with your bae mom for
years
when that when everyone leaves your life
sometimes you sometimes your brother can
be a grizzly bear
you know i mean you trying to get some
[ __ ] she turn over
you'd be like [ __ ] it let me just go
ahead and go to sleep
yo she wake up go to work your kids go
to school then you go back home and you
turn that good porn hub boy
yeah oh listen
last week my producer right
he was like you know he got roommates
and he was like yeah you know charlie in
the bay and frank frankie's gone so i
got the house to myself tonight the
first thing i said i said oh you're
gonna beat your dick all over that house
tonight
hey the best part is with the volume on
you you'll be facts oh you remember that
[ __ ] still got to be super low yeah you
know when you when when it when when the
kids are around or you know you got the
door locked you got
you you kind of imagining the sound you
know what i'm saying yeah
yeah or you got to let that [ __ ] down
you know i mean you got to hit the
button you got to hit that [ __ ] all the
way down
all the way down where the sound is off
yeah you just gotta tap that [ __ ] one
time
just so you can hear this so tiny big
yes a tiny bit like me and mustard was
talking about that [ __ ] bro me and bro
we we all can relate bro a hundred
percent and and i'm about to start
writing records for women as well like
like i might start writing records to
send them off because it's a lot of [ __ ]
about me
that women can relate to that i know
and i don't have no pride and i can tell
the truth about myself you feel me
a hundred percent and everybody know
that from my raps to my instagram
everything people know that i got no
shame either man
to a fault it is what it is that's why
people love you yeah man i'll be myself
like i'm always be myself bro no i think
i think uh
you know
as long as you know when we think about
longevity in the music game right and
the people who have really like lasted
all these years i think for the most
part the number one thing is in whatever
capacity is is
it's
being genuine
being apologetically you
yeah
and i ain't trying to [ __ ] on nobody
like i ain't trying to talk to nobody
crazy i ain't tryna you're very positive
bro you got positive vibes bro if you
follow you on instagram you're like yo
this dude is a nice guy bro i don't even
think it's positive vibes brought this
thing
it's naturally bro
nobody is raised to be disrespectful
right
point-blank period
nobody is raised to
to to to just go out there and hurt
people rather it's physically
spiritually mentally like that
but alone away
people forget how they was raised bro
you know what i mean
that's real
so
it's crazy because i take this [ __ ] with
me like i take i take you end up getting
like all the uh outside [ __ ] in your
life ends up kind of retraining you from
how you was raised yeah and like just
about this whole rap thing like my mama
my mama bro my mama
my mama
i'm gonna say like she'll see a dude on
the internet or do it on tv talking [ __ ]
or whatever and she'd be like i hate a
cocky [ __ ]
she always said that right so that's why
i'm like bro no matter how much money i
get
i'ma always
you feel me hey i wipe my ass you wipe
your ass right
you wipe your ass with the right hand
you right handed i wipe my ass with my
right hand right so we're on the same
level right
money don't change money don't change a
[ __ ] it just changed the status
of a person bro that's it
so like i see you [ __ ] what's up what's
up like it's good ask me how many other
questions you want shake my hand
whatever
it's good i'm normal just like you bro
like that's it give me some of your
other history on like just your come up
man in the music game because obviously
you know we we'll get to the you being a
mailman and all that because i think
that's that's part of your story but
just
you're making music at what point in
time did you start taking like music
serious were you actually paying for
studio time and like you know what i
mean um
okay
break it down okay um so i always wanted
to rap right my first thought i'm giving
you from beginning to end all right make
it fast
my first the first person was to put me
in the studio was my big cuz of smoke
right because he was a rapper too he
lived out in kansas city
you hear me he lived and can't like take
nine that was real i was gonna say shout
out to tech9 you feel me like that yeah
like he just always he he made us want
to rap man
so i just like i'm i'm a rap hit me as a
kid i'll be a rapper hot boys and [ __ ]
like that so he put us in the studio
real young
and so
along the way i just got away from the
studio but i always wanted to rap i
hopped in the streets you feel me was
hustling
you feel me and
2013 came i got hit with a dope and gun
case
so i hopped back in the studio when i
was about i was like 16 17 2013
i think so
tell them
i
i uh got a break
they gave me height a height it is
um
basically you finish your probation you
feel me you pay your money you can get
all your felonies off
i i hid out in my granny basement my mom
was living down in houston texas
bam
i'm down there watching
wiz um
where's youtube channel i'm watching
nipsey hustle crenshaw
bullets don't handle that i'm just
watching these guys and watch how they
move i'm watching casey veggies
kennedy i'm watching
family schoolboy q i'm watching this
2013 14 years it's a great blog the blog
area of hip-hop is my favorite era man
bro you know this is going to go to not
writing two dope boys and all that [ __ ]
y'all feel me so i'm watching on the
west coast
got off
2015
i made it out no no another dope no drug
cases no gun cases and i tell my mama
just come down there and do something
different ain't got no felonies let me
get the [ __ ] on up out of here
damn left went to houston
bam
but i'm searching
because i know what type of song i like
i know i want my videos to be i know i
want my videos to be so i ran into oh
shot you and which is the my camera man
who shoot all my [ __ ] now oh shot you um
and uh uh um
i ran into uh
a red studios here engineer you're gonna
see him with me here with me today
man so 2017 i started putting out
records right
i had a formula
record with a red
shoot the video oh shot you
i need some promotion let me get on say
cheese ass shout out sean cotton
we feel me so
i was emailing sean cotton he wasn't
hitting back
all right
so i just said something about him in my
raps then he posted me hmm
damn
that's where it go
i finally got the plug now
they email them back every time sean
cotton will see me in that damn email
he'll take it
and
he was trying to be funny at first but
he didn't know he was helping me
he like
yeah rapper that uh bfb rapper
girlfriend gives him chlamydia
right just don't know [ __ ] free promo
you must not know i i got no shame in my
game yeah [ __ ] what i'm living like
this yeah
all it is is a by the way
all it is
is a penicillin shot to the ass and
three days on the bench and you're back
and you're back back over here
and you're back
you gotta sit on that bench for three
days you feel me i still love my [ __ ]
my [ __ ] gave me gonorrhea but i still
love her that was the line that was just
that's that [ __ ] like
yeah that's
er since then it was on
so
every time i would put out a single
he would he would throw that in there
girl gives
you feel me
[ __ ] get mad at this right
right right right my [ __ ] like bro why
the [ __ ] you keep doing that whole ass
[ __ ] bro relax damn see the vision i see
the vision like it's free promotion come
on people are paying for that kind of
promotion
you getting it for free
come on man bro they don't under bro
they don't see this internet [ __ ] i see
that's where i'm at where i'm at right
now i ain't got no shame my [ __ ]
i ain't got no shame em it's the truth
i ain't no no six nine [ __ ] no you ain't
do it yeah for sure you just that what
he was doing was a lie that wasn't him
you're being you unapologetically caught
an std for my [ __ ] and i still love her
you feel me that actually happened i'm
really living like that oh facts okay
that happened so water came on my mouth
but we good that that's clean water my
mouth clean
um
minus the chlamydia facts facts that was
years ago yeah so
bam as he doing that my father was going
up i'm going from five i started at four
or five thousand
bam i jumped to team then i jumped to
seventeen thousand
and then like i just kept going kept
going kept going just the same formula
record the song with a red nice
professional mix
great video then i'm doing this [ __ ] all
off a work check because i promise i
promised myself i wasn't going back to
the streets right
you feel me
bam
a red says you need a feature
right
so i'm like damn what are we gonna get
i got this card shout out to macy's man
i i felt that full credit card and they
gave me four thousand dollars
right
so i had some cheese saved up and i had
the four thousand dollars on a credit
card
bam i said man
my brother had just got out of the
prison
he bumped inside of every day he watched
his side of videos like a [ __ ]
right so does that guy in detroit for
sure
so
i post again on say cheese that's why i
say
i don't say cheese like before before
but before i say cheese it like to get
my houston buzz am i used to following
up how [ __ ] know about me in
houston texas was this blog called stay
down productions
stay down productions 2.0 bro
if
to every artist out there if you need
if you need
a texas buzz
that's basically like mainly strictly
texas hit up stay down productions dm
them get at them for for promotion man
for show
like for real facts but um
say cheese right
i posted uh uh uh uh
to go play
soda comments on it see one thing about
say cheese say cheese is a big blog all
the rappers follow that press all the
labels on like everyone's following say
cheese and ours that you got uh 300
followers a thousand followers that
report to the big [ __ ] to come sign
you they follow and say cheese
[ __ ] yeah
that's why i tell [ __ ] promote on say
cheese and stay down productions bro
cause you got jazz prints and all the
[ __ ] who signed drake and uh all the
[ __ ] following state all productions
and
trying to tell [ __ ] bro [ __ ] don't
be listening but anyways side of
comments on it so man my brother bump
inside of every day he just got out of
prison
solid
let me go get shout out for the
featuring video
we get solder
it's not like i can't do it that low
like the amount of money you offered i
can't i he i can't do it that little bro
remind you saudi is dropping it he
getting a million
in three days right right right he's
doing 10 20 that [ __ ] doing numbers you
hear me yeah for sure
please
bruh like i want to but i can't it's
just too it's just too cheap a video and
a feature it's just too cheap
what were you offering him
man i can't say man well you had four
grand on the credit card and a little
bit of money from the from the work
check
i can't i can't say me i can't say it
wasn't quite enough it was it wasn't bro
and i'm i'm gonna talk to bro and ask
them can i start saying how much
you feel me
but um
so that happens can you say how much he
wanted
brosada was getting like rosado probably
was getting like ten thousand what does
it say i was gonna i was gonna say he
was probably getting ten right like ten
ten's the number one
he's probably getting like 10 000 or
probably i don't know so you ask him you
pretty much say please and he's please
he like man
yeah i mean
bam so
and the song's fire cotton is low-key a
fan of me but he's not giving me no
conversation he's not [ __ ] with me at
all right right right right right
i got this [ __ ] number i'm hitting him
and everything cause one thing about me
i'ma find a way right so i got his
personal number i'm hitting him
everything right
bam
what happens is the [ __ ] sean cotton
ends up telling us how to like bro you
do it with it i'll post it
try to hit me like hey
i'll do it bro sean said he gonna post
it whatever we do
what the [ __ ]
what bro
bro that [ __ ] support but he was not he
wasn't texting
and like that's what let me know sean
like a straight up [ __ ] all right he's
straight up he 1000.
he's hearing me like
damn so we finally we finally get it in
the pandemic too yeah we finally shoot
it
he comes in the studio later verse like
two verses
went extra crazy in the video he
directed he like [ __ ] thinking oh we
gonna do b-roll [ __ ] i didn't know what
no [ __ ] b-roll was like
no saddle went overboard for that measly
ass
bro
crumbs right
damn damn four o'clock roll around
they leave thank you bro what you do who
we go back in here hey real like [ __ ]
you ain't about to leave me you bout to
help me clean up cause you know soda bro
brosada roll with like 10 [ __ ] and
they all like bring 13 [ __ ] and they
all be straight in the middle of
coronavirus in the middle of corona
booked this studio right he packed that
he booked it he booked my studio he
booked both rooms
and both of my engineers are running
sessions for his whole team right
and they call me and they're like can
you please this is there's there's
there's pit bulls and guns and smoking
no one's wearing masks this is like this
is like
probably may of last year this is like
in the thick of the rona
and i pulled up here and i saw what was
i said man listen guys we're running a
rap studio here so every once in a while
you're gonna have to deal with some [ __ ]
like this i am not telling these young
men from detroit nothing right they paid
good money to be here
they got the spot for the night it is
what it is facts
and they will smoke a good weed man
couldn't hardly breathe in that [ __ ]
yes and i don't smoke and they made a
drink or smoke they made a [ __ ] mess
they made a mess it's ashes blunt fills
everything so hey real life [ __ ] ain't
going nowhere you bout to help me clean
up first
so i'll go in there and help bro clean
up mind you it's four o'clock i gotta be
at the post office
hey
i gotta drop my kids off at daycare i'm
a daily daddy this is real life this is
real life these are real life issues
yeah i get them i i go to sleep for
about two hours bam get up get them
ready drop them off at daycare take
masks to work
hey red
a red mix the song the next morning [ __ ]
that the old shot you oh shot you got
the video back
we put that [ __ ] out
um it was it was it was it was up from
there
uh uh 400 and [ __ ] 60 000
followers
um i don't know how many ever views on
instagram i mean i don't know however
many views on youtube i don't know
how many views [ __ ] on instagram i
don't know how many streams later [ __ ]
but i'm here no for sure i'd like to
point out that i'm 99.9 percent sure
that i actually dm'd you before
but let's see what did you do
but when did that song come out
june
okay i hate you in october then so i hit
you after i hit you after i trip like i
said bro by the way
i apologize to bro cuz that's
disrespectful this [ __ ] is a goat he is
like a legend that got been watching his
[ __ ] for years man i'm a fan bro i
think i think um i just like unique [ __ ]
in the game and i think that like your
bars are like so relatable to my life
i'm like dawg i'm just i'm like yeah man
this is how we talk this is the [ __ ]
i've been through in my life
i've i've had
my share of i've had to sit down for a
few days you know what i'm saying i mean
man bro if you really out here [ __ ]
bro you caught a std
for one because [ __ ] feels great and
for two
the [ __ ] should be so fine you be like
bro i gotta hit that [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] it it's worth it it's worth the
trip to the clinic
it's worth let me stick that dick in raw
let me look man i gotta feel this
[ __ ] oh i gotta feel it
i gotta feel it i really really like her
too or not if i really like her you
could just be
like oh i want to [ __ ] her but you ain't
seen no [ __ ] you wanna [ __ ] and you
going through your mind like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] raw i want a nutty hurt
once upon a time in my life i was that
guy for sure once upon a time
i'm a married married man my wife is
beautiful i love her
but
past tense past tense
for sure
come on man
i got a question shout out to the hook
of hookah hookers facts so how long you
been married since 2018 but i've been
with my wife since 2016.
2015. yeah
rihanna say
hey kev
you want to link up
for sure
for sure
2015 2015 2015 reread 215 reread
she said kev you want to link up
of course
of course
yeah but you got to hit this line of
cocaine oh for sure
yeah i'm not gonna lie i might give
another dude a hand job to [ __ ] rihanna
in 2015. if she was like look we could
[ __ ] with you gotta jerk off my
bodyguard i might think about it
i might think about it look i asked i
asked any [ __ ] i'd be like bro what's
your favorite look i'll be like bro
what's your favorite what's your
favorite because riri and there's no
disrespect to rocky this is 2015. this
is where we're about we currently are in
2015.
at the time she's no disrespect to rocky
i'm talking about at the time she's
sleeping with drake on the side she's
not currently like seriously locked down
i don't think you know about that 2015.
so we're in a time machine yeah but i
say that to every [ __ ] that i run into
not but but first i asked him like bro
who is your celebrity crush but i just
use riri because she's the baddest
youtuber she's a woman well she's also
like
like a safe person to use right and she
is [ __ ] beyonce before whole before
marriage will hold
you know i mean she's the baddest she's
the unique she's the she's the queen
and let's be honest like rihanna
probably got way better draws than
beyonce like i feel like rihanna's
definitely a probably a lot more
crazier when it comes to uh you know
them sheets maybe i'm tripping but i
would i would bet my money that
rihanna's with all kinds of [ __ ] that
beyonce may not be down for
like i bet you rihanna's eating asap
rocky's ass for sure
if i had to bet my money on it i bet she
is
like if you had if you had a [ __ ] a
paycheck on it that she's that she's
that rihanna's eating now she's eating
ass for sure
[Music]
yo
anyways man yeah so what i was saying
was what he was saying was that 2015
that i just use rihanna because she is
the imperial you feel me like she's the
imperial [ __ ] riri is that [ __ ] she
land like that [ __ ] and
i just want to hear
what would a [ __ ] do for an imperial
woman
like one of my homies he loved nikki all
right i said bro
[ __ ] nicky said [ __ ]
if you want to get with me you got to
hit four lines of coke that [ __ ] said
i'm hitting them [ __ ] for sure i've
never done cocaine by the way me neither
me neither that's why i'm like i don't
do drugs right see see me
i love lizzo
i know this i'm really lame like that i
see you putting it out there so if she
say pat
you got to hear some coke what if she
said can't jump in this couch what if
she said you got to shoot heroin
to jump in the couch i'm up out of here
it's a no but you but i can't do it but
you're down for cocaine
no hell no so listen
lizzo says you gotta hit this coke
you're saying no bro listen
i love wiz khalifa to
i wholeheartedly love that [ __ ]
i keep my uncle or something that's my
brother for sure
that [ __ ] said pac
you gotta hit some weed when you come
through this next time
i said whiz i'm never coming through
i can't i can't hit no
bro it's just some of my body with drugs
i just can't do it like i got drunk
bro i can't like i'm a sober [ __ ] bro
so you're you would like
just leave liz
would you smoke weed for lizzo
i hit it one time one time okay
no cocaine but you do the weed
i do the weed one time just so you
turned it hit it just hit it like
just a little bit
what what what um inspired you to be so
drug-free in such a
non-drug-free industry that we're in
[ __ ]
for one
excuse me for one um
my father
uh
smokes crack
right
that's my [ __ ] everybody know that he's
i said it in my songs yep um
i don't know if that's because
i don't know if that made him ain't [ __ ]
that or he just ain't [ __ ] dad
you feel me
cause sometimes drugs have changed
people for sure for sure especially
especially certain drugs yeah so
and then on top of that man i just used
to see people on the corner and strung
out
like bro you see that [ __ ]
if you from the hood bruh
you grew up [ __ ] if you're not from the
hood if you grow up out in beverly hills
and calabash is way up like when you go
to l.a you see people strung out
bro you know what this [ __ ] gonna do to
you why do you want to try right
so you got to see the
the darkest side of the drug [ __ ] hell
yeah that's how i was i already
struggled enough with food my [ __ ] i
hear you i love fool me too
me too i mean obviously we're we're i'm
not as uh
i got the dad bod popping but
that is my one vice man
if i could eat all day
like when i'm when i like peak pandemic
me
i'm waking up
i'm just eating all day i have a whole
ass dinner as soon as i'm done with my
wife's amazing mexican food she might
cook i'll eat two bowls of apple jacks
fruity pebbles rice krispie treats are
fire they get too soggy in the milk
though after a while it's like what am i
eating fruity pebbles that's a hood
classic listen
he's just [ __ ] i would eat all
[ __ ] day man it's like it's like and
then i think i said applejack's he's a
legend
he's living like that but yeah but the
drug [ __ ] is like for me like all my
family was all heroin addicts and meth
meth fiends growing up because i grew up
in like in phoenix in like a area called
sunny slope which is kind of like uh
it's like a
it's like the white trash trailer park
hood you know what i'm saying
mexican hood and it was like my whole
family was always strung out in and out
of prison and [ __ ] so i never yeah
what's your ethnicity i'm just german
and irish just a white dude you know
what i'm saying
but uh but i never that's why i never
[ __ ] with no heart i didn't i didn't
start drinking until i was 21. i never
even [ __ ] with alcohol i drink sometimes
but uh
i've never done any heart i've never
taken a pain pill bro i've had surgery
and [ __ ] and i was refused to [ __ ] with
the pain pills cause i'm like man i know
my my lineage of family
they're addicts so if i take a [ __ ]
pain pill who knows where the [ __ ]
that's gonna take me in life you know
what i'm saying like i might get hooked
on that [ __ ] nah see and that's the
reason why i'm like bro
i can't do it and we and we was in the
we we 95 like 90s babies
you were born in 95 yeah okay i was born
in 87 so yeah so we 90s babies
we
our air was so much crack and coke we
was zany babies for sure we we pop his
annies
right you feel me do [ __ ] like that well
also it's the era you grew up in the era
where it was
normalized to be a user
through music facts you think you're
like zany percocet like we peel babies
think about mask off by future
this so
this song is so crazy this song is so
crazy when you hear it like the whole
hook is talking about doing percocet
like yeah
like it'll ruin your whole [ __ ] life
you know what i'm saying like i was we
we just watched money bag yo's video for
wakisha
like right before you got here i had it
on the tv
and i was like i used to drink syrup you
know that well that's a drug
i used to drink syrup uh like 2 000.
yeah i mean that's a real like 15 i was
a young drinker that's a real ass drug
though that's opiates but watching that
waikisha video i was like this is like
the craziest like
song because it's like you go to the
club and it's like one of the hottest
songs in the country but if you if you
really listen to wakisha
he's just explaining to everybody how he
is addicted to lean and he relapses and
goes through withdrawals and like
it's if if you really break down the
lyrics to that song
it's like
it should scare anyone to do the drugs
because somehow you sped 400 grand on
liam i'm like bro this [ __ ] is crazy
and
yeah it's a different era man
yeah yeah um
again back to
my habit
the shirt
activists
tasted so damn good bro
oh
that's the problem right it tastes good
oh
that's the problem tasty taste yeah
it's a problem with me not i like it
like it was that and
yeah bro i just love that take that
sweet [ __ ] that sugar bro yeah it's that
put it when you put them with the soda
and assistant
yeah so i wasn't drinking again it's so
close to your other addiction yeah
no i wasn't drinking it right i was
drinking because the [ __ ]
me bro
anybody who was a real drink head
no
when you get that when you taste that
syrup
your body just be like
going down it could be just a little bit
out the [ __ ] thing and you just
but i went cold turkey 2015. did you
have withdrawals
hell no bro so you you you were like i
went back i wouldn't i was every couple
days bro i went every day oh yeah cause
you know if you if you like if your
body's used to that [ __ ]
yeah it's tough to get off that [ __ ]
yeah i went like every i went like yeah
i got to talk to schoolboy q about it
like it was telling us like when he quit
how hard it was because of the pain your
body goes through and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] crazy i [ __ ] with school boy cute i
can't wait to do a song bro yo he's
probably like top three most funniest
dude in all the rap if you like actually
know him he's a maniac he's hilarious
you guys would [ __ ] love each other
yeah and you guys would be it would be a
sh it would be just everyone would be
dying laughing in the room bro real [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you something about like
guys with humor
you know cause in this rap game in this
business everybody wouldn't be tough
everybody wouldn't be shook like [ __ ]
you not tough like relaxed bro
it's a little [ __ ] that's five three i
gotta knock you off bro relax
and i don't wanna be like that like i'm
like the cool guy like guys
like that but they're right you feeling
but everybody want to be tough and [ __ ]
and like i hate that that's one thing i
hate about
people bro like everybody especially
people in this culture like it's like my
[ __ ] relax bro
my man's over there blow you
pause and we
and we just sit right here until the
police come all right that's crazy like
bro just relax like
just relax
but we but we good are we cool whatever
but it's like that sh i hate that [ __ ]
bro because like
it's the people like your favorite
rapper
your favorite artists don't have no
character and that [ __ ] like you
all right
this is true school boy i [ __ ] i [ __ ]
with him and that's what made me a fan
of him because like his rapping to me
he's the hardest person out of tde
i i know a lot of people who feel that
way and i see it he's i mean listen
scoreboard queue is amazing man
and then that like man like man that is
it's the the stories that he was telling
the the way that he raps it's like bro
he tells the story you don't even have
to rhyme right just like we just
listening like
pow pow pow pow when he was wrapping up
uh
um
i forgot what's that [ __ ] called
when he's basically telling how he was
growing up on hoover mm-hmm he said he
was like yeah god god like damn [ __ ]
hearing them say cubs made me a fan
[ __ ] i was like bro
well you mentioned a lot of l.a rappers
so you're you're really uh
like a fan of the of west coast hip-hop
in general yeah yeah i mean you
mentioned i mean casey like you said
casey veggies early had a wave like him
and rocky fresh put out a tape together
that [ __ ] was crazy like
you know i think that uh
talk about because you know you being
from flint what is the the relationship
between michigan and the bay because
there's something there
we just had payroll giovanni up here and
you know he's
does so much [ __ ] with so many bay area
artists like
i don't know it's like y'all on the same
wavelength listen i'm being in the back
seat as a little fat kid hearing big
tama tama right
41
right
sprinkle me man like
[ __ ] not my daddy not my mama boyfriend
[ __ ] my mama it's just me my mom and my
brother in detroit listening to 40 or in
flint flint sorry flynn how far is flint
from detroit 45 minutes
totally different places i apologize
y'all get the water situation together
no that shit's crazy
we won't dive into that but that shit's
crazy yeah but
that bro
that was like
bro e40 fan bro e bro
if i don't know why
hey man e40 in the click axe payroll
same thing e40 in the click
he riding around with this daddy
yeah
bro i don't know why the [ __ ] them
[ __ ] were so heavy them bay area
[ __ ] was so heavy in michigan like
that i don't know why and we far as [ __ ]
away from each other very far hey
interrupting the interview to tell you
about our good friends at odd socks now
as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying oh shout out to my
bony ass knees um listen go to
oddssocksofficial.com they got all the
craziest socks these are the outsiders
you know what i'm saying they got
spongebob they got cheech and chong
listen breaking bad godfather
whatever you need they got it and now
they have underwear that's right you can
get your odd socks underwear the boxer
briefs are the best underwear that you
could ever fit on your ass trust me when
i tell you these are chucky draws
what you know about top ramen underwear
all right go to oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20
off of of your order
underwear masks slippers
socks whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
heaven check out save 20
what so prior to you
when i think of flint and hip hop i
think of john connor and i think of m.c
breed
that's that's kind of like the lineage
and you know john connor is a crazy
lyricist signed to shady for a while i
mean he's a very talented guy now you're
[ __ ] on fire so like like was there
any sort of like scene in flint that you
had to like look up to or was it like
um
yeah we looked up to dayton family
though oh dayton family was crazy for
sure oh you heard dave of course yeah
yeah yeah we looked up the dayton family
yeah like like michigan in general is
like such a
it's such a
[Music]
diverse hip-hop scene there's like [ __ ]
all the way over to the left
where it's like eshaam and insane clown
posse
and then it's eminem and then it's j
dilla in slum village and then over here
it's you know doughboy's cash out and
peasy and all it's just it's such a [ __ ]
we grew up on dope voice cash out see
when you mention doughboy cash out where
you gotta like nobody's cash out was
like the first [ __ ] to actually
and in our era 95 and down babies
94 and down
damn [ __ ] inspire us like a
[ __ ]
geez he came to get there my dog hosts
not just one but uh
because they were kind of from
a different side of detroit that didn't
necessarily have
because big sean was active
but sean wasn't like from from that side
of
sean wasn't sean was sean was like
like
how the [ __ ] can i say this
sean is not a street rapper
but don't mean he ain't from the street
no i didn't say he wasn't i know sean
very well that's my dog but i just mean
it's in terms of like
the subject matter and his music yeah it
ain't like street selling like that's
always casual that's what i'm saying
no that's what i'm saying yeah i mean
i'm not saying yeah me [ __ ] we riding
downs oh [ __ ] uh
we on the west side [ __ ] and we [ __ ]
we got spots open [ __ ] we counting pros
we got
true religion zone right [ __ ] we [ __ ]
we live in we popping rose and dom p
[ __ ] we rocking minks
our signs and [ __ ] like that you know
dope was cash out payroll them them
them [ __ ] inspired us like a
[ __ ] bro
yeah i mean then like two years later
nigga's name peasy and dang
see
i don't know if y'all know about dane
bro i don't know about dame but i know
about pz
p the first i remember in high school
they like yeah we [ __ ] with double a
cash out but y'all heard of peasy and
dang
see when people speak about like
detroit right they forget
they they forget something they need to
be like payroll you know because payroll
from the west or they'd be like peasy
peasy from the east but no it was team
team eastside was from the east side
though boys cash out was from the west
and they historically don't those two
sides of town don't get along right i
can't really speak on detroit right
right right you're not from don't know
about that that's fair that's fair but
growing up in flint i'm telling you how
i heard about these [ __ ] and
they came team eastside is like
different like they sound what's
different it's [ __ ]
from doughboy's cash out
and
peasy and dang they like peasy and dang
y'all got to get on damn dot bro go
check them out like they they was all
team east side that was team east side
was was was babyface raid and that's why
[ __ ] so happy for right now
because he's killing it i mean he bro
these bro they was a it was team
eastside
team eastside snoop baby face ray
uh uh uh love p
uh uh peasy dang dot
all these [ __ ] just doing their own
separate thing now you can google damn
dot you can google uh peasy they're not
[ __ ] face rain yeah pieces with
empires snoop got
had uh lost his life give me rp smooth
summer mine [ __ ] like bro
like yeah but
but then the guys that we grew up that's
what you yeah that's yeah we grew up on
dope boys cash out and team team nissan
for sure um
you're currently you know the new album
is out it and it's it's it's a great
project it's you know i've been seeing
a lot of uh good things being said on
twitter about as far as the feedback
you're getting from the fans young indy
[ __ ] man we we
bro i ain't got no problem my [ __ ] i do
the ground work
[ __ ] i'm like i'm running i don't
tell me when you say indy
are you like who are you doing the
distro kid the tune court thing like how
are you like distributing your music uh
to uh
orchard okay orchard okay okay through
the orchard so they and they distro they
do distro yes
sony right sony orchard yeah yeah
yeah i get them 50
you feel me
they they uh
they give me like
jpeg like [ __ ] that tunecore couldn't do
yeah they give you a budget they'll help
i i i get it 100 yeah like they like
they
they gonna give you the money
right
but
it ain't like no guidance like that like
[ __ ] is
here we go
all right here's the money what are you
going to do with it that's on you
you got to make sure your team is
together you got to make sure you know
what you need one day i called and was
like yeah they asking for what's name
what's that he said oh you got to pay
them
i'm like oh so you're like bro you still
independent bro mm-hmm
you like [ __ ]
major labels
was this your first project through
orchard
okay
so
prior to that you were just doing the
distrokid thing huh yeah no tunecore
tunecore
tunecore district same [ __ ] like yeah
and that's what my manager was like bro
yeah bro like
we gonna help you my [ __ ] like we're
gonna help you uh
[ __ ]
that's why it was p people was because
the big labels was hitting me
like the label labels of course it's
distro
so
i mean free joe exotic is such a big
record independently that [ __ ] is crazy
that
like that was such a moment you know
what i'm saying like
it's the kind of record that could
change anyone's life yeah and that's
when my mans was just like bro
you wanted to be independent they could
put your big boy drawers on me
mm-hmm dude do with your [ __ ] so
i just turned it up like i was just back
at back back
when i was um
didn't have no record just making
relationships just trying to do whatever
so i'm like [ __ ] it let's get out here
so everything you see
from this relationship with these
artists to
me doing this [ __ ]
that's that's that's me running up on
[ __ ] tapping the [ __ ] dm getting him
hey tell him i got this [ __ ] tell him
i'm trying to say
like me like i'm i'm running on the
ground
so
you mentioned that you've shot the video
with soda baby the next morning you had
to take your kids to daycare and then
you had to be to work at the post office
at this point in time you have a
a distribution situation with a serious
distributor that you just put your new
album out
um are you you're still not working at
the post office are you yeah you still
are yeah you have to be part-time though
this this hot is right so
after i come off tour after i get done
running around i go back home and go
back to work
still to this day still to this day
it's not no [ __ ] not no [ __ ] bro
i swear
on baby jesus and and for people who
don't know you know my best friend in
the world is uh he's worked at the post
office for 15 years so the benefits are
off the chain you feel me
yeah
that union is off the cha you could take
a leave of athens absence for as long as
you want
see the beauty thing the beautiful thing
about the post office is they won't fire
you
that's some real [ __ ] unless you do some
foul [ __ ] unless you mail steal me right
but outside and there's some [ __ ] like
that and and it's people that stole mail
that's still working that [ __ ]
yeah the union broke the union's got you
you feel me
yeah you're mad as hell why tyree that
about people be hating bro
people be hating you
yeah my boy anytime some [ __ ] happens
like he'll cut his like hand at work or
something i gotta call my union rapper
yeah i did
man come on bro you know what's going on
how long how long do you plan on keeping
the job like like in all seriousness
like you're you don't need it you know
what i mean like i'm not saying that
it's not good you have kids right so
it's not it's a good thing to have
benefits and have some sort of security
but like
realistically for your career to kind of
take it to take to the next step you're
gonna need that bandwidth right
yeah probably
probably when i assigned to a major
which isn't even necessary by the way
i'd like to point out it's not it's not
it's not
but
the thing is right with a major right
that's what i that's what i'll be
wanting to tell people
you got to have somebody in the building
mm-hmm
that's how you're going to be successful
yeah because you got someone in the
building and the meetings fighting for
your [ __ ]
yup
once you get that [ __ ] in the
building
you're good
do you feel wanna do it's gonna get
clear
if it makes sense right right
do you feel like um
you'd like that that's your next you
know because
this you you have the big features right
you you uh
you're getting shows
you're doing things that a lot of people
aren't majors aren't doing you're doing
numbers that a lot of people who are on
major labels aren't doing
what is the one thing that you think
they can bring to the table that will
make a difference
because i i see it like you could still
you could run up your indie catalog for
another two or three years so what i was
see
one thing about me is
when you approach me bro
and you a solid [ __ ] right then you
want to do business with me
even if we don't do business i'm going
to keep you around
you're going to be my friend right
cliff joseph my man that's my mans
if you're in a music business
you might or might not know cliff joseph
solomon songs
savvy davis on instagram savvy's my guy
yeah sav we're we're both the only sons
fans in the rap game that we know
kendall this is real name you know
yes all these guys all these guys um
gary that's that atlantic
you feel me dallas that's that atlantic
bro i keep all these [ __ ] close
to me they all are hands reached they're
all homies right
it's just a matter of
i hear what they do when they like an
artist or when they like a a record or
when they want to push a record
radio costs a couple hundred thousand
dollars 1 000 he's about to put ain't no
indies about to put no bread on you like
that unless you sign with empire
do you feel
i don't really know i don't know we i'ma
get you i got to get you with ghazi you
know what i'm saying
there's a cheat code
man but ain't no indies is about to go
like
like
ain't bro
no
majors is gonna put the bag up
majors got good relationships they've
been had relationships so [ __ ] [ __ ]
before we was even here right he was
born in 87
i was born in 95 right
they've been here before both of us nwa
came out when
around the time i was born pricks came
out win for sure no you're right michael
jackson was like win how would you say
this priority records was like win which
is a which is
uh with like
aristo records
uh owns i think uh
a lot of the old [ __ ] uh
like bro these record labels been here
since the 60s and 70s you think that
you
is worth more than a relationship that's
been getting paid
that they've been doing business with
since the 60s
how how close were you because of like
with free joe exotic you could have
taken that record to any major i'm sure
and then they could have put the bag
behind their radio they could eat it all
that like it didn't make sense it didn't
make sense plus i didn't know the
business see see see you got to learn a
business bro yeah
so i'm like [ __ ] it let me do the indie
route let me take this little bag that
the indie guy but while i i'm over here
and pay my bills pay attention take care
of my kids
it's going to be a roller coaster ride
let me learn a business let me float
it's going to keep me afloat
i'm just going to do the work i'm gonna
learn the business though
you have to learn the [ __ ] business
man for sure
so
in that time
i'm learning the business while i'm with
this while while i'm while i'm with this
indie
i don't want this distro right why am i
saying anything i want this dish yeah
so
that's what i've been doing i've been
learning the business it's a lot of [ __ ]
that i didn't know
it's a lot of [ __ ] as we as artists
don't know we don't have a clue
that's real and they wanted they wanted
to stay that way man that man them the
majors they gonna lube their hand up
they gonna [ __ ] you raw straight up lube
they dick up and [ __ ] you wrong man
and why they [ __ ] you is
so you can learn a business and they can
profit at a large expense
so i'm like [ __ ] it
let me do this right
let me learn a business
that's what you're doing
and the new album is out and the album
is something that like i feel like
is a real statement you know because
it's easy to put out i won't say it's
easy i don't want to say that but
putting out singles putting out moments
one at a time but to put out a cohesive
body of work is is a whole other thing
story you know i mean fat [ __ ] you
know them skits was really real like
that's that's really [ __ ] that happened
in my life as a kid a chick really did
tell me the reason why she didn't want
to be my girlfriend as a little kid
because i was fat and ugly
you know i mean
that [ __ ] made a beast you're in me
that [ __ ] got about six kids now oh i
bet right you feel me she's probably fat
as well
she blew up
i don't know i haven't seen the [ __ ]
i feel like i feel like most of them she
got about six she got about five six
keys now it'd be hard for any woman to
have six kids and not be at least 10 15
overweight
that's a lot that's a lot of kids i mean
that's a lot of bounce back you're
bouncing back all your 20s at that point
i mean dj emmy wife no if you got about
like six of their seven
and yeah but they're slim yeah they're
rich so i think that's that
say not no chick from the hood yeah yeah
i don't know i think you got money you
get the trainers right you get your diet
right you know i mean i mean
yeah
but yeah
do you are you so how many kids you got
i got i got two two kids how are they
three or four
and uh are you still with the baby mama
yeah
is that something that's like
hard to do pull off the family life and
still be on the road still do the shows
how do you do it man cause like i think
a lot of people just do it
you know bro
my baby mama been with me since before
this rap [ __ ]
and you know when i be joking on
instagram and i'll be posting like oh
she outside right right or you know tell
2d i want my no it's dumb [ __ ]
to be like oh man she got that [ __ ] for
that money like but you know i've been
here way before this [ __ ] right right
right right
hey you know what i think and that's why
i say like
this is why i say
this is why i hold it down for us fat
[ __ ] man
because when they see a fat [ __ ] they
think of
oh he stank
he don't got no [ __ ] mm-hmm
the two fat things
i mean them the two then the two fat
most things they think stereotypes
you're getting no [ __ ] and you stink
facts okay
this is the natural fact
of this [ __ ] bro
like
you should see the comments i'll be
looking at the comments like bro y'all
really think this
y'all really think this
i know she ain't giving anything you
know y'all really think this huh
okay
well i got a boy listen and then they'd
be so curious because you go to a [ __ ]
patrick this big mama ugly than a
[ __ ]
or the [ __ ] ugly as hell like man
listen do you know i gotta i gotta bro
oh my god you yo yo ain't here wanna eat
this [ __ ] [ __ ] if you if she see her i
got a [ __ ] so bad [ __ ] y'all ain't you
want to eat this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yo
mama you watch your mind [ __ ] and i had
her before rap [ __ ] and i don't pay
these hoes nothing why'd they be
thinking that
baby oh that's another thing they think
i'm a fat trick i was gonna say in your
song you say you like hookers
bro my [ __ ] i like
hookers
meaning i like hoes you know why i like
hoes bro
cause there's so many secrets to a good
[ __ ] a good
oh
i've never done this i'm a good woman
and then you find out that she got a
train ran on her by the
offensive line of the national of the
tennessee titans and
07. no i'm uppity i'm a good girl huh
man i'm good girls man i'm [ __ ]
them them [ __ ] have to be having so
many secrets and they be sneaky my [ __ ]
the hoes at least you know what you're
signing up for off the rip look look at
it look in the industry bro look at the
industry look at what happens
bro sometimes a hoe can be
a a a a good girl
a good wife
you know why why because most likely bro
she was probably touched as a girl you
feel me as a girl not as a woman right
as a kid right right trying to touch
that's a girl she probably was abandoned
so she probably thought like
daddy
like [ __ ] like that bro i'm from the
streets i'm from the ghetto i seen this
[ __ ]
i've seen good women i've seen i've seen
i've seen [ __ ] bro i'm talking about
[ __ ] who used to get trained right
now
bro they end up getting married right
you know why
because they can see their flawless they
can see they they they true what they
self yeah i used to do that that was me
i was young i was hurt right i was this
i was that
about them good girls don't be [ __ ] bro
i'm good girls let me just be sneaky
then be the sneaky hoes [ __ ] did you
them [ __ ] had to cheat on you man
face yeah
or at least got the secrets
for sure bro be re i'm realistic with
this [ __ ] bro fact so
uh
i know you you know you said it had to
be such a big deal for you to work with
whiz right
whizz is uh
one of the dopest dudes in the game
because he's like the kind of cat where
he'll only do something if he [ __ ] with
like the the like
he's only doing a record if he likes the
record
and if he likes the record
chances are he's just doing it right
like he ain't charging you
like i don't think people understand
that about wiz like you think whiz will
hit hit a lot of these young up and
coming cats up 100 000 nah if he's [ __ ]
if he [ __ ] with the music he's gonna do
the record because he wants to because
he's like that's just how it is you know
what i'm saying
you you went you didn't have to pay for
the wiz verse right i'm assuming
well this is something that
wiz is pretty open about we talked about
it in an interview i did with him like
man i'd be having the eggs man i'll be
happy to find out from people man i'll
be one no no he openly said like if i
you
if i [ __ ] with someone [ __ ] don't matter
how big they are like i'm gonna just do
it
he said meanwhile this guy's like well
he didn't do that for me i might need to
put a call in
like i don't wanna i don't i don't wanna
speak on
like like one thing about me bro like
not saying i don't wanna rub nobody the
wrong way and nothing like that i just
be wanting to
[Music]
say this
i don't be want to speak the wrong
you know i get it you guys i'm going to
say the wrong [ __ ] you always say the
wrong [ __ ] damn like you were supposed
to keep that between us like now i get
it
and then i'm at the moment like oh damn
bro
you're right you're right hey look i
respect that man it's like what else
[ __ ] like if we have a if we have a
conversation off air of course i'm a
real guy bro i'm i'm like a real person
i respect him i'm not about to you know
boot me a boolean care talked about that
behind
yeah i'm just going to leave that there
what are your future aspirations i do
feel like you're
so funny yeah i feel like you could do
movies you could i want to you could do
all of it man i want to bro
that's some that's that's bro i'm
linking up with zack fox bro i'm trying
to get a tv show i'm trying to do bro my
life
on the road bro [ __ ] something bro
sometimes [ __ ] get mad
cause we play so much and we crack so
many jokes and we like [ __ ] be bound
to fight on the road bro
and we still be laughing
that's so funny i want to break off in
acting
so bad bro
they told me to move out to l.a
they like bro
please move out to l.a you going
first off you're going gonna link with
everybody you're gonna do good music out
here for one for two you're gonna you're
gonna break off until you're acting out
here bro if you do just keep like an
address in houston's you don't pay the
shitty taxes here because the taxes here
are the worst
yeah it's bad um
listen the album is a homage to all the
fat homies out here yeah i'm kidding and
the real ones and the skinny dudes man i
ain't singling nobody out i want to know
though
let's talk about some fat some fat dude
[ __ ] real quick because come on let's do
it
i always have these debates with the
homies let's start let's rank can we
rank
from top to bottom
the
the fast food chains in the in the
country like when we're talking about
the mcdonald's the taco bells the burger
kings the wendy's in and outs all this
this give me your like top five
fast food chains one to five
[Music]
i can't do i can't do the proper order
okay
but chick-fil-a
will chick-fil-a be number one i don't i
can't do the problem okay okay okay okay
no order chick-fil-a no order bruh
chick-fil-a
for one and forever bro mcdonald's is
always a good classic i don't give a
[ __ ] if you don't eat the [ __ ] now cause
it's nasty no no no let me say this [ __ ]
cuz i i say this [ __ ] all the time
mcdonald's is fire as [ __ ]
if it wasn't so [ __ ] fire
it wouldn't be the biggest [ __ ] in the
world this [ __ ] is fire
is it good for you are they in greek it
tastes good that's it's
if it wasn't so [ __ ] good it wouldn't
be the biggest [ __ ] in the world they
got their own coca-cola there bruh
their coke tastes different than all the
coke in the world
all right mcdonald's we got to put some
respect over mcdonald's be out here
getting disrespected bro i'll pull up
with that [ __ ] give me a double
cheeseburger give me the mcdouble put
french fries inside of the burger extra
ketchup give me the spicy mcchicken
[Music]
i just spent two two dollars and i'm
on make it big sense man ain't get the
orange high c in the high seas he's
about to say it you took it out of my
mouth they brought him back they brought
it they brought it back they knew what
they was doing they knew they was
[ __ ] bugging when they took that [ __ ]
off the menu
bro all right real [ __ ] so
chick-fil-a mcdonald's
um
[Music]
believe it or not
i grew up it was a wendy's in my hood
what is this fire
wendy's spicy chicken nuggets yup
fire fire
get a frosty frog man frosty on a hot
summer day big umph put some fries in
that [ __ ] man you ever you ever put dip
your fries in the frosting i haven't bro
ah to be honest bro i really been trying
to lay off like the fat i'm getting too
big i'm not talking about now i'm
somewhat in life you've never you've
never did the fries at the front but but
i eat my fries with my frosting not dip
it in there all right but it's the it's
you eat some fries
chew them up and then before you swallow
before all the fries down the throat you
put some ice cream back in there and
that [ __ ] tastes so good but i never
just blatantly ate it like that
the wendy's uh chili's a movie
back in the now you remember back in the
day
wendy's used to like have a little like
bar like a little like soup like bar
like you get the baked potato there and
they would have all the ingredients
inside and you put like sour cream in
the bacon bin wendy's just listen shout
out to wendy's i love wendy's yeah we
got two more
man i will say taco bell but they [ __ ]
up my stomach
last time i was in la man i had a real
bad stomach ache bro
so taco bell
taco bell i really got i ain't feeling
them right now so i'm just leaving my um
[Music]
i never really seen like no arby's here
you [ __ ] harvey i love harvey's
i love rv's we got the meats
and everyone hates on armies everyone
everyone says it's [ __ ] yo my boy uh pun
i just saw they were arguing on twitter
saying black people don't need orbeez
man they capping bro let me tell you
something [ __ ] my [ __ ] [ __ ] my baby
mama i gotta stop calling my baby my
[ __ ] my girl her mama got mad at that
and my mama cut it to me about that like
stop calling her yo [ __ ]
listen
orbeez my girl you know cause arby's
just like
they got them curly fries the curly
fries my [ __ ] with the horsey sauce oh
i like the arby's sauce that beef and
cheddar all that [ __ ] melted cheese
man
see i [ __ ] with arby's arby's is a dark
horse for sure because nobody talks
about arby's thanks they really got the
meats thanks and the chicken sliders
they sliders go dumb [ __ ] and they're
like a dollar
get the ham and cheese
who's holding down the five spot
i'm a flint [ __ ] bro i'm a michigan
[ __ ]
okay and this franchise was made in
michigan
and
rosa parks was about to get put out of
her apartment
and the owner
of this franchise
pay her rent
up until she died
little caesars
five dollars
and by the way
little caesar's pizza
is better
than pizza hut and dominoes that's for
sure
when you go to flint i'm gonna take you
to get a stramboli [ __ ] you ever ate
one of them no yeah that's real flint
[ __ ] bro see see people think about
michigan they think about detroit right
but no
you gotta go to
40 you got to go 45 minutes north
okay
will you hop off [ __ ]
when you hop off that plane
in metropolitan mm-hmm go go go go 45
minutes north to look to lost town
called flint
get you some [ __ ] little caesars and
let me tell you we get you some
[ __ ] life familia [ __ ]
all right get you get you some life
familia
get you some uh
get you some uh get you some yayas
get you some halo burger get you some
big johns that's real flint [ __ ] and
then you gotta turn on the flint artist
let me get hold on wait wait wait for
all the [ __ ] anars at these labels
[ __ ] shout them out man
i had a face shout out to my baby mona
leo name
she [ __ ] she she inspired me to
do this
but anyways back to
you know what i mean
if you're artists at these labels bro
this sound that you're hearing coming
out of michigan bro
it's a flint song okay it's from flint
pay attention to flint
we got rio de jungo g
who free him
from
we got ysr grams we got
grind hard e
we got [ __ ] crispy life kid
we got king cashes for the record crispy
life kid is is a
that's an amazing name
like if he opened up a restaurant i eat
there
we go we got wire star grams
[ __ ] we got [ __ ] we got we got
we got we got jeff skye
jeff scott's the [ __ ] kendrick
lamar [ __ ] shout out to flint
go scoop these [ __ ] these [ __ ] gonna
[ __ ] these [ __ ] gonna sell king
caches
i'm trying to tell you if you're er at
these labels bro go grab some flint kids
do it
i'm trying to tell you do i gotta say
the names again
louie ray
grinehar e
crispy life kid king cashes
ysr grams
flint
darrell rich flint
please go uh no no i got the real rich
don't worry about him you already i
ain't got him on paper yet but i ain't
worried but they ain't about to go grab
nobody out of flint anyway they gonna
wait till [ __ ] pop anyway um
jeff skies that's how it works man
that's the kendrick lamar flint oh watch
that [ __ ] video i'm trying to tell you
[ __ ] y'all gonna wait till these
[ __ ] pop they're gonna be like damn i
heard pac-man said in the interview he
said it first
y'all gonna wait to these y'all [ __ ]
gonna wait til these [ __ ] get a hit
record man y'all gonna wait till these
days catch a little buzz y'all gonna
wait till they get 100 000 followers on
instagram then they gonna call they
gonna call and i'm gonna be right there
like hey
make them [ __ ] get you a 50 50 split
no distribution fee
i'm be giving them [ __ ] all the game
that i had to learn [ __ ]
well make them make them
i don't even know the name of it i don't
even know what's the proper language for
but let them hold the masters for like
10 years or five years and then they
return back to you um
i'm gonna be giving them [ __ ] the
sauce [ __ ] cause y'all [ __ ] don't
want to go pick them up right now and
i'm telling y'all well look man the
album is out flint michigan [ __ ] i'm
trying to tell you
your album is out
it's fire
thank you more videos coming i just saw
you shooting the video with coyla ray
i saw you like leg leg pressing coil ray
koi bro fat i want to tell everybody
this bro y'all keep your [ __ ] mouth
closed bro
for real
how about koi [ __ ]
coy a real person bro when she real cool
as [ __ ] me and she don't disrespect
nobody she seems super nice i haven't
met her yet but real talk she had a
gangster you heard me
and she hit harder than the [ __ ]
she was punching me in my back [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was hurting low-key mm-hmm i
kept trying to move she's like no no
packing around
hitting me hard as hell she'll [ __ ] one
of me all up mm-hmm
i better quit playing with koi like that
not for real bro for real she'll [ __ ]
up
is a very beautiful person bro very nice
very respectful [ __ ] her mama showed up
[ __ ] her mama real loving like it was
like a family right there and her team
like they took over the whole spot that
was playing games like bro they really i
really really love court like bro it's
like this is why i love wiz this is why
i love
zach fox this is why i love like
so many so so many different people
because
bro they show up and they get a good
vibes i didn't been in the room with
other rappers i hadn't been around other
rappers in the [ __ ] and the vibes
trash trash for sure but yeah man shout
out to koi that's the next video
i'm assuming yeah that's one that's
coming next fire shot by jdfm that's my
brother from phoenix arizona man that's
my boy jd man jd films
go get you a video from phoenix's own
yeah facts and go get you a video from
my [ __ ] i'll shout you to a beast we
about to we about to get him together
that's my brother from the mud [ __ ] we
started [ __ ] shooting videos for 200
[ __ ] [ __ ] he gonna be getting a
hundred thousand videos in july at the
end of 2022. well there it is man the
album is out go support it by the way
shout out to uh the honorable mention
taco bell that's mi5
that [ __ ] hurt my stomach i think i
think they gave me some bold lettuce bro
i think something about taco bell i
appreciate is just the innovation no
[ __ ] i love taco bell grew up on taco
bell the innovation though every time
you go to taco bell they got some new
[ __ ] that they rolled out and it's some
[ __ ] that like you had to be high or fat
to think of
like let's put fritos
in a burrito [ __ ] i use taco bell
seasoning for my tacos oh yeah thanks
you dashing for the grocery store you're
going crazy baby jesus now oh listen
appreciate you pulling up
my guy thank you go get the album thank
you boom
yellow lunch crew